dwayne johnson says he won't be
returning to the fast and the furious
franchise and he's calling out vin
diesel's quote manipulation after making
a public plea to come back here's the
thing about it right so we're all adults
while speaking to cnn the rock admits he
was quote very surprised by his former
co-stars request
saying quote this past june when vin and
i actually connected not over social
media i told him directly and privately
that i would not be returning to the
franchise
the actor adds quote i was firm yet
cordial with my words and said that i
would always be supportive of the cast
and always root for the franchise to be
successful but that there was no chance
i would return
that's the way you got to do it the last
time the two men appeared together in a
fast and furious movie was in 2017's the
fate of the furious
it ain't too late to stop this
but vinon duane reportedly had a falling
out on set which became public in 2016
when the former wrestler called a few of
his male co-stars quote candiaces and
unprofessional on social media
and fans were quick to speculate that he
was referring to vin the feud is
something the jungle cruise star
addressed while speaking with et in
2017. just like in life you have
different philosophies and people have
different philosophies different
fundamental philosophies on how you do
things
and again the most important thing is
just the movies fast forward to november
2021
and the guardians of the galaxy star
extended an olive branch to duane on
instagram
asking him to return to the franchise to
quote fulfill his destiny even after
their long-standing feud quote my little
brother dwayne the time has come the
world awaits the finale of fast 10. as
you know my children refer to you as
uncle dwayne in my house there is not a
holiday that goes by that they and you
don't send well wishes but the time has
come legacy awaits i told you years ago
that i was going to fulfill my promise
to pablo
pablo is of course vin's nickname for
their co-star paul walker who died in a
car crash in 2013. dwayne tells cnn that
he didn't like that vin brought up
paul's death and even his own children
calling it quote an example of
manipulation
so while there may be no future for
dwayne in the hit movie franchise he did
open up about the possibility of
pursuing politics including if he'd ever
run for president as a result of high
public demand he calls the whole thing
quote very humbling but ultimately says
quote i still don't know a damn thing
about being a politician i don't know if
i have that politician gene in my dna
leader yes patriot all day long
politician no
but when dwayne spoke with e.t in
january about his sitcom young rock
which centers around him running for
president he didn't completely rule it
out let me just give the the the
audience now just to contextualize what
it is the show takes place in 2032 and
in 2032 i am running for president of
the united states we thought that that
might be a fun pathway in creatively so
i'm involved in every episode and
looking back on my life and on the
campaign trail i would do
what the people would want me to do i
will just leave it at that in the future
so when that time comes uh i'll do what
is
what i feel is right by the people and
what they tell me